so thanks for coming to this session my
name is Daniel Bulgarian and I'm going
to talk about machine learning for
personalized health so um I'm not a
software engineer I'm a machine learning
researcher and um this is a subject that
I'm really passionate about so I do work
with with software developers and
engineers as well on these sorts of
problems
so I'm gonna give a high-level overview
on machine learning for healthcare and
how we can run machine learning models
to personalized health so just a bit
about the research that I actually do so
most of my research is based on using
problems to graphical models for
understanding disease heterogeneity and
the ideas that a lot of diseases are
probably misclassified and the evidence
we have for that is that the same
treatments for a given disease doesn't
work for everybody in the same way so
with latent variable modeling a lot of
work I do is trying to understand this
heterogeneity based on different symptom
profiles over time and how you can
caption certainty around disease
diagnosis as well a lot of the data I
have is longitudinal data so I do a lot
of analysis around long as you know
these analysis a problem that's inherent
in in data especially in healthcare data
is missing data so a lot of the work I
do is actually formulating probabilistic
models around missingness what sort of
inference can we draw out missing data
what are the assumptions how it could we
incorporate those assumptions into the
models we make oh so look a lot at
causality this is very important in in
health and a lot of the work I do has
two characteristics one is that it's
multidisciplinary so I work with social
scientists with engineers and with
clinicians to try to understand
healthcare systems and understand health
as well and the work is very patient
centric and I think this is really
important that the patient's is at the
center of this this sort of research and
the patient's is what motivates this
research as well because sometimes we
can think about think about clinician
empowerment but here what we're thinking
about is patients in power
and how to help people take their health
into their own hands
so why personalized health care well I
spend quite a bit of time working in the
pharmaceutical industry and in the
pharmaceutical industry this is
typically how you set up an experiment
to test the drug so you have a group of
patients with some disease and you split
that up into two populations one
population you give an intervention or
some drug that you want to trial and the
other population you give a control
which is usually what's already on the
market so you wants to see whether the
new intervention works better than the
control and hopefully your intervention
works better so you can put that drug in
the market and you run your favorite
test statistic to compare those two
groups and compare the number of
patients cured in the new intervention
group compared to the number of patients
cured in the control group so hopefully
you have a success with with the drug
but actually what we see in real life
once the drug goes out since in markets
is that even though you have the same
patient's group with the same disease on
the same prescription they respond
differently to treatments and this is
the whole motivation for looking at
machine learning methods for
personalized health care so some
patients may benefit from the drug and
there are no side effects with other
patients there are toxic side effects
even though their benefits and sometimes
the benefits don't um don't compensate
for the toxicity of the drug some
patients don't respond to the drug no
side effects and some patients not only
do they not respond to the drug but they
have really bad side effects I think
this is the sort of thing you see a lot
in cancer treatments as well that not
everybody responds in the same way and
what we're trying to do is to understand
why so the focus of of this talk and a
lot of the work I do is on and the type
discovery and this is the grand
challenge to try to understand subgroups
of complex diseases that even though we
have a single diagnosis for disease
maybe they're multiple syndromes within
that common diagnosis and this can help
us to understand what's the underlying
mechanism that drives those those
differences in response to drugs even
though we see the same
symptoms on the on the surface is there
some way we can identify different
subgroups and this is a foundation for
the stratified medicine we're trying to
seek better more targeted interventions
to doing that by trying to understand
the heterogeneity in disease symptoms as
well so any type comes from the greek
endo which means containing and type
which are things with common
characteristics and disease has
originated here's something that we see
a lot where you see not only
heterogeneity and how symptoms are
manifested over time but that
heterogeneity and drug response which is
really what we're trying to guess heart
so with endo type discovery what we're
trying to do is is identify a subtype of
a condition and the main characteristic
of an endo type is that there's some
pathophysiological mechanism that
underlines what you see on the surface
so the general framework for identifying
disease and the types using public
graphical models so this is like the
general framework that that I used some
of eight throughout this talk so the
squares at the bottom are phenotypes or
things that you observe so these could
be different different symptoms that a
patient comes into the doctor with and
you have some sort of latent variable
which isn't directly measured you can't
directly measure it but you can infer
the presence of that latent variable or
your endo type based on the observations
you see over time which are your
phenotypes so just to make the
distinction that not all subtypes are
any types so an endo type means that a
particular subtype of disease has a
different underlying mechanism and this
is something that's very frequent mostly
in psychiatry data and in yeah in
psychometrics so examples of I think
where it's more obvious applying these
and the types are in things like mental
health conditions or in IQ tests so for
example with depression
you can't directly measure depression
you have to ask a series of questions
and you can infer some sort of latent
variable that um can help you to
understand whether someone has mild
moderate or severe depression and
therefore get the right treatments for
example with IQ testing as well it's the
same you can't directly measure IQ but
you can infer based on a series of
questions so this is the same sort of
philosophy that we're trying to use with
with symptoms as well so for probably
stick programming which is the general
framework for discovering these and the
types as well we have this problem
program to identify what is the latent
structure based on the series of
symptoms we have so in a probabilistic
program you have some probably stick
model which expresses the general
knowledge about this situation so very
often you go to your favorite clinician
that you're working with or
collaborating with and I have my
favorites and you you sort of try to try
to quantify how they see the world what
is the domain knowledge how they think
different symptoms are correlated what
is correlated and what is causal and try
to put some sort of parameters around
that in a problem model so probe lesyk
model expresses our general knowledge
about a particular situation and we have
evidence which is the data and contain
best contains specific information about
this situation and we have some queries
that we want to ask of this of this
probe listing model as well and this
expresses things that will help us to
make decisions on clinical outcomes and
then we have an inference algorithm
which we use to answer the different
queries and we get an answer to the
queries which are frames as
probabilities of different outcomes and
their different ecosystems for running
these problems like programming models
so the one that I mostly use is infinite
Nats which is a Microsoft inference
engine on c-sharp so you have some
problems like program that you put
Annette's compiler and you get your
probability distributions and there are
other ecosystems as well so Piru is a
new one that's come out stan is quite a
standard one as well and edward and
they're these different problems these
different ecosystems for doing
problematic modeling but the particular
one I've used this infernal net so now
I'm going to motivate this in in asthma
and allergic diseases which has actually
been where the bulk of my research has
been over the past eight years
so with asthma the hypothesis is that
asthma is actually an umbrella term that
actually is several different diseases
because what happens is when someone
especially with children with children
it's very hard to make a diagnosis of
asthma because the lung isn't developed
until they are seven years old so if a
child comes into a clinic they'd have
these sorts of symptoms they have
allergy poor lung function their
wheezing they have symptoms that look
like asthma they going out in and out of
hospitals in here for steroids and a
doctor would see them and say this is
asthma but actually what we see is that
there they're different responses
medication and also different
manifestations of symptoms over time so
some children may growl savasana some
respond to treatment some don't respond
to treatments and some develop asthma
later in life so what we're trying to do
is think well are these actually
different enter type or different
diseases with different causes so I'll
motivate this with two problems the
first problem is trying to understand
what is the asthma and a type or subtype
in a population-based both cohorts of
2,000 children so this is data from the
Manchester asthma allergy study in the
UK and we had the primary care records
for children in the first eight years of
life and also we asked their parents
questions every year to see whether or
not they had symptoms of wheeze or
asthma and what we're trying to do is
identify whether there's some
Thanks underlying genetic or
physiological marker for these different
subtypes of a sloth so this is the
modeling strategy we have the observed
variables which are your GP records so
GP is like general practitioner so it's
the electronic health care record for
particular trials and we assume that
that's the ground truth so we give it a
rating of 1 and then we have
observations from parents of the
children in each year of life so each
each parents every year they are asked a
question on whether or not they've seen
a child's wheezing in the past 12 months
and also about asthma medication as well
so we assume that there's some latent
variable which is your true current
wheeze which we don't really know
whether that's our small or not we just
we and also it's very hard to measure
wheeze and we assume that there's some
subtype of whisky but we don't know the
number of these subtypes and we don't
know how many children are on each of
those subtypes as well and we model this
through a longitudinal logistic
regression model and we assume that the
probability of a particular child's
wheezing at a given time point is
conditioned on what is the probability
of being a member of one of these
subtypes or endo types and what we found
when we did that is that there are
actually five distinct subtypes of
asthma so asthma is actually a
heterogenous phenomena and if we look at
the profile of children's of children
over time we see that if we assign
children to their highest posterior
probability class we forget these five
sometimes and just at a high level what
we notice is that there are two groups
of persistent wheezes or you could call
them what you classify as asthmatics a
lot of children girls have asthma a lot
of children get asthma later on in life
but the orange and the red line the sort
of ones with the two highest
probabilities are what we call
persistence
persistent wheezes and the red line
which are 13% of the population we
classified as
systems controls wheezes because they're
the ones who respond to treatments and
the orange line which is 3% of the
population are the ones that are really
interesting because they're the ones who
don't respond to treatments so we call
them persistent troublesome wheeze
Oh in this next line you see we could
see that more clearly so on the
left-hand side the top line which is the
orange line we see that those are the
children who are receiving inhaled
corticosteroids so they're receiving
asthma treatments and the next plot we
see their hospital admissions and
whether they're going to hospitals
receive inhales to receive oral steroids
which is a severe infection so even
though these children are on treatments
they're still being hospitalized so they
asked us not being controlled where's
red line is being controlled so
essentially we saw most patient where we
can actually discover these sorts of and
types in in asthma and we notice that
they're 4 different subtypes of asthma
and possibly these subtypes represent
different data types so we have a group
of transients early wheezes late onset
wheezes persistent troublesome wheezes
and possess and control tweezers and
we've done some further work and we
realized that these also have distinct
genetic and environmental associations
as well and different responses to
treatment and I was really exciting when
I was working in you know grasses
SmithKline at the time that there was a
drug being pattern to market at that
time that got um that got FDA approval
and this was for a particular subtype of
asthmatics
I can't remember what the drug was
called but basically the development of
the drug was based on identifying what
are these different biomarkers that can
help us to distinguish um different
subtypes of asthma and it was
interesting to see that movement who was
developing more personalized treatments
and management strategies of asthma in
particular and of disease in general so
this is something that can motivate
looking at other disease areas as well
the second example I'm going to motivate
based on trying to understand subtypes
of disease is something called the
allergic March I don't know if this is
something that's very prevalent in the
US but actually it is prevalent in the
u.s. as well probably in sitting here at
Africa areas more so than others and
this is a hypothesis around why people
develop allergy or hay fever or rhinitis
so I use those terms interchangeably so
basically in medical textbooks you see
something like that plot with the three
sort of squiggly curves so this explains
why people get hay fever so the
hypothesis is that in early life you
have eczema then it causes you to
develop a smelly tone and life and there
it causes you to develop rhinitis or hay
fever later on in life and this is how
people get allergy so who cares well the
reason this is important is because this
is how drugs are developed this is a
motivation for developments of drugs for
hay fever so the idea is that if you
stop eczema and early life you can stop
people getting here fever later on in
life and we wanted to see whether this
actually works in real life so again
using these progress stick graphical
models we wanted to capture disease
heterogeneity and encapsulate these
different patterns of symptoms over time
and the idea was to understand the
problem stick dependencies to identify
some sort of meaning meaningful latent
structure and understand what are the
dependencies between those symptoms at
the time so we assumed some priors some
DeRusha priors with equal probability to
each class and again we don't know the
number of latent classes or the size and
we calculated each child's posterior
probability of belonging to a particular
latent class so this was done on data
from two geographical locations in the
UK so those two where the arrows
Manchester and Bristol there was a total
of 12,000 children of the 11 years and
in the first model we ran a hidden
Markov model where we assumes that
eczema asthma and hay fever or rhinitis
independent
so the probability of observing ax
murder given time point is conditions on
what happens at a previous time point
and the same with wheeze and and
rhinitis and this is governed by some
overarching Layton's class in the second
model we actually explicitly inferred
allergic March where we assumed that the
probability of rhinitis at a given time
point is conditions on the probability
of asana at the previous time points and
conditions or in the probability of
eczema at the previous time points so
similar to an allergic March and the
third we just assumed that there's some
longitudinal latent disease profile of
the time and symptoms can be independent
so you have some latent state of disease
at each time point and the xml wheeze
and rhinitis aren't necessarily linked
over time like a hidden Markov model so
then we compared the models using model
evidence and when you test different
priors and also different numbers of
classes we found consistently that the
third model so that's the independent
conditions of it across time that's the
best model if you use a tallit and
classes and if we look at that we saw
that actually what we see on a
cross-sectional level so if you look at
all of the children in the world today
you would see a profile similar to
neurologic March but actually only 3% of
children follow something similar turn
an allergic march on an individual level
and most people have eczema by itself
wheeze by itself and rhinitis by itself
so the take home message was that
actually there's heterogeneity in these
different profiles of symptoms over time
and it's not a single causal condition
so there's heterogeneity on an
individual level for these different
symptoms and their difference
co-occurrences
so an attack discovery can lead to
better understanding of underlying
biological mechanisms for different
subtypes of disease and probably a
graphical modeling is an intuitive
framework for incorporating prior
knowledge for any type discovery and
I've also touched on some of the
different challenges which have not gone
into too deeply for this talk around
looking at cohort data and trying to
understand these profiles on a
population level so there challenges
around missing theater actually trying
to infer causality where you where
you're not sure sure what the time
sequence of advances and also estimating
treatment attacks I think one of the big
take-home messages from from this work
is the importance of clinical context
that is really important to think deeply
about the clinical context to find
solutions which are specific to the
problem and this also motivates for
doing into the superior research as well
that in the machine learning researchers
need to understand the problem and also
the engineers working on the project
needs to understand the problem as well
and also we do a lot of work with social
scientists to try to understand the
context very deeply and this is what
good science is about is about merging
different schools of thought to develop
a bigger picture as well so the approach
is very much problem led it's not just
give me the datasets but we need trying
to incorporate domain knowledge and
secret data driven approach to machine
learning for this myself
and this is what team science is about I
think this is something we can't drive
home enough that discoveries about
healthcare on not necessarily
hypothesize a priori but have to be
helping me by experts explaining
structure learned from data by
algorithms tunes by those experts and
there's a need for heuristic blends
between different difference on
disciplines so these are a lot of
collaborators that works with on these
projects and also I'm currently working
on at Microsoft Research in Cambridge
and how
care team and um in Microsoft there's
lots of great work going on in the
healthcare team so two of the flagship
projects a project called Minar I which
is looking at medical injury imaging
temp our clinicians and also project EMA
which is using wearables for traumas
associated with Parkinson's disease and
I think these are two really good
examples of really trying to understand
the domain to find solutions to these
problems using machine learning
approaches but then thinking how can we
translate these machine learning
approaches into technology that actually
helps people so I'm going to show a
video at the end about projects Emma and
I think this is really a good example of
how we can use these sorts of
discoveries 10 power people and change
lives
[Music]
okay all right I'm gonna try and
replicate this here after a great start
I tend to kind of just avoid doing
sketching or writing now because it's
just it's not really worth it if you get
something like that anything you could
do that would just make my hand do what
I want it to do and go outside my name
would be an incredible thing
how do we even just begin to help her
overcome this particular symptom of her
tremors and helping her be able to
regain her writing ability her drawing
ability so what I'm doing is I'm making
a very rough prototype and what this
board does is I can connect into it
through these wires these are tiny coin
cell motors so these motors will vibrate
I personally think that what this is
doing is its short-circuiting whatever
feedback loop there is between the brain
and the hand that's causing the the
tremors so the idea is if you are
distracted by the vibration are you able
to write better I don't know it's
affecting something I don't quite know
what's happening I'm onto something
right I'm onto something
[Music]
Oh
Jesus Christ
oh god it makes me forget that I have a
Trevor
[Music]
would you wonder then for a long time
I've actually just written my name for
like the first time in ages well it's
called the Emma it's got my name
[Music]
Thanks
I think this is a really nice project
showing how how research can be used to
improve human life and to really empower
people by understanding the problems
deeply that people face so that's it
from me thank you very much for
listening
[Applause]